I'm Rick Levin the president of Yale
University and it is with the greatest
pride and enthusiasm that I am here to
introduce you to Tom Stites the winner
of the 2009 Nobel Prize in Chemistry Tom
Stites came to Yale in 1970 as an
assistant professor after training at
Harvard and University of Cambridge and
he has been a leading figure in the
sciences at Yale for his entire career
for that entire period
he's a towering figure in the field of
structural biology and the prize that
he's been awarded honors work that he
carried out over a long period of time
to identify the crystal structure of the
ribosome one of the most challenging and
difficult problems in molecular science
Tom's contributions that Yale span the
range from having the department chair
to having been a leader trainer of great
students and a devoted citizen of the
university we've all been waiting for
this for many years as Tom's great work
was initially published in 1998 and then
in 2000 on the ribosome and it takes the
Nobel Prize Committee to a little time
to figure these things out but we were
confident that they would come around at
some point and recognize the
extraordinary work that he has done I
want to recognize also before I turn the
microphone over to Tom that he is this
is a well supported scientist he has
colleagues who have been great
contributors to the to the to the
progress of his own work in particular
Peter Moore his longtime colleague and
the chemistry department here at Yale
and topsites has a rare family because
his wife Joan is one of the leading
scientists at this university as well a
pioneer herself in in molecular
biochemistry a has have served also as
chairman of the department of molecular
biophysics and biochemistry is also a
great citizen of the university and is
also someone who we hope someday will
get the same recognition that tom has
gotten today Joan Stites thank
it's a great pleasure for me to
introduce to you then to Professor Tom
Stites well it's a pleasure to be here
of course it's thank you all for coming
it's it's a very exciting moment and I
have to start out by saying how much I
owe to Yale and how much I owe to my
colleagues of Rick Levin mentioned Peter
more I'd like to mention Peter as well
because he's been a friend and colleague
and co-worker and Co collaborator for
many many years and certainly on the
ribosome so I very much appreciate his
his company and his work and his
participation there there are lots of
others of course who have been important
over the years in the department
I remember Fred Richards who was a
person who hired both of us as well as
Peter as well as Don Engle one as well
as many others in the department and I'm
so sorry that he died in January so he
couldn't be here because I would like to
share this moment with him because I
credit so much to to Fred but it's been
a wonderful environment and it's been
just a true adventure to see structural
biology develop at Yale and to be able
to work on all these exciting problems
that we've been studying over the years
and finally culminating in 2004 the
structure of the large ribosomal subunit
and I have to say that was that was an
exciting moment because what we were
seeking this as a quest we tried for a
number of years we started in 1995 and
it seemed to us a bit like trying to
Mount Everest that is we knew it was
doable in principle but we didn't know
actually whether we were going to be
able to get there and we didn't know
exactly the route through which we
should travel but we found the right way
and then when we got to the top in 2000
that was very exhilarating in fact the
most exhilarating moment I've had in
science to to peer into the inner
workings of the ribosome and think about
how it works and our goal in working on
the ribosome was to understand the basic
molecular biology and biochemistry I
have always been interested in basic
research and I think this is what the
NIH does and should support but it it
has as so often it's the case practical
consequences often I'm seeing I don't
think well I for one that wasn't
thinking about the ribosome has been a
target of antibiotics and that this
would be useful I was never crossed my
mind but then we did realize that this
was the case and we looked at the
structures of antibiotic complexes and
then Peter Moore and several others
helped fine acts of to help to found the
company Rybak's pharmaceuticals which is
located in 300 George Street and the CEO
is Susan frosh our and and they've been
working very hard over the last number
of years to use our structural
information plus information that
they've been able to get subsequently to
design new compounds that might serve as
active antibiotics and I have to say
they've they've been extraordinarily
successful much more than I had
anticipated one always worries whether
these things are going to work but
they've done
calculate Java so I think they are going
to have antibiotics that will be active
against methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus mr RSA that they have the
compounds already and one has finished
phase two clinical trials and hopefully
it'll make it through phase three and
then be out there in the world so III
think it's important to have practical
applications of research but I think one
has to realize how important basic
research is to get started and then then
stuff happens what you've it's very
interesting I'm gonna make us a lay
person suggestion to the press people
here if you go to the either the Nobel
Prize website or to Tom's 2000 article
in science you see the picture of this
thing and you know for a layperson it's
amazing to think anybody could figure
this out I mean a ribosome
is immensely complicated it's a great
big structure with lots and lots of
things in it and the idea that you that
you could infer exactly what the atomic
structure this thing is you know um it's
like a giant mystery it's a it's an
amazing piece of work I think you can
you get an appreciation just look at the
picture of what of what professor Stites
and professor Moore and their colleagues
have managed to do it
it's just fundamental sweat it out
figure it out you know science it's like
solving a gigantic jigsaw puzzle about
one of the most important fundamental
you know aspects of biology because
after all this is the protein machine is
the factory that makes the proteins that
that are the source of life for all of
us so it's it's a fabulous
accomplishment we're so proud and
pleased that that Professor Stites and
Yale have been recognized today thank
you all for coming